You ever smell a scent
and it reminds you of something that you've eaten before?
Ever since I started using the Mason Margiela Replica
Afternoon Delight fragrance,
all I can think about is making vanilla custard.
Reminds me of all the moments I spend in Paris
indulging in sweet afternoon pastries,
especially those with a custard base.
The scent smells warm and sweet,
and you can really smell the vanilla in it.
I started making my custard,
bringing it to a boil on the stove,
and I pulled it off, added my vanilla bean,
some butter,
whisked that all together before pouring it into a bowl to cool.
After a few hours, it was the perfect consistency,
so I plated it up. I always need some strawberries with my custard,
and this was the perfect afternoon delight.